[Music]
I'm sorry this conferences loves video
effects I've gotta got to do it alright
so today we're going to talk about
loading on the web loading is a user
journey with very disparate expectations
you're basically sending thousands and
thousands of bytes down the wire and
hoping that whatever comes out from the
very end of that is something that's
actually useful to your users and helps
them interact with your applications
relatively quickly so I thought that
today we'd have a conversation about
loading now we can really have a
conversation about loading without
talking about where we're at right now
so this is what the average web page on
mobile looks like in 2017
whether it's built with sort of a
JavaScript framework or just a static
site in many cases it takes 16 seconds
to get interactive on a real mobile
device on 3G usually takes 19 seconds to
be fully loaded and people mostly send
you know somewhere in the region of 420
450 kilobytes of JavaScript down the
wire and why does any of this actually
matter well if we take a look at a high
level and how the browser actually
manages to get anything render to the
screen from the network it's a
relatively simple process we send a
request out server returns an HTML we go
and we parse the CSS and JavaScript and
images and anything else that comes back
and then we actually have to parse
compile and render that code in order to
render and turn onto pixels on the
screen right but it's never quite that
simple we're usually developing on
relatively powerful high-end desktop
machines and the expectations that we
have when we're profiling there are
quite different to mobile particularly
when it comes to things like JavaScript
startup performance where on a real
world mobile device you can end up
seeing anywhere between 4 and 5 times
with a slowdown so the first thing I
think that we as a community need to
shift worth doing is actually testing on
real phones and real networks
I know there are a bunch of people so
how many people here actually used like
the dev tools network emulation or CPU
throttling or device node so a lot of
people here that's great that's a great
first step we need to do better than
that though because mobile devices have
got different GPUs different CPUs
different memory different battery
characteristics so there's a lot that we
can do there for people that want to
start doing that today we recently
shipped the new part of webpagetest.org
called slash easy so webpagetest.org
slash easy has got a whole farm of
average mobile devices on there right
now with easy profiles for going and
checking out your performance now a lot
of the time we talk about mobile
performance these days we reference this
idea of time to interactive and the idea
there is that you're just able to make
sure that the user can actually tap
around your interface and how something
useful actually happen in this case I
think that someone is going through like
a withdrawal symptom because there isn't
actually anything on their phone looks a
little bit dead so there are a few rules
that I like to follow and I'm building
modern web apps that try to load
efficiently the first is only load what
you need so trying to make sure that if
you're shipping script and CSS and
everything else down the wire that it's
only the things that are going to
actually be useful to the users initial
experience that you're using idle time
to load in anything else so your comment
threads any additional pages that might
be needed for the rest of the user
experience now there are a lot of things
that we can do to actually help load
less code one of the first things is
code splitting so code splitting
something that a lot of you probably are
familiar with as a concept relatively
straightforward get set up using webpack
were split able or closure compiler or
browserify the basic idea is that
instead of like making your user eat an
entire pizza and get really bloated you
just give them a single piece at a time
and that way hopefully they feel you
know a little bit better about the
experience that you're shipping down
tree-shaking so removing unused exports
using things like roll-up also worth
spending time on something we don't talk
about enough is the fact that the
baselines we're using when we're trying
to ship powerful experiences on mobile
don't always set us up for success today
so if a framework for example and I love
I love frameworks I created two MVC ela
frameworks I use like reactant view and
free
all the time but the frameworks that we
use today are often built with desktop
machines in mind and when it comes to
actually trying them out on mobile if
we're saying you've got to be
interactive in like five seconds and
your framework is beating up like four
seconds of that and it's do it at time
that's not setting you up for success so
there's probably room that we've got to
improve there there are lots of
lightweight options today pre-act view
svelte polymer there are lots of others
they generally have a relatively though
parsing startup time over on the dev
tools side one of the things that we
recently shipped to help you with this
idea of shipping less code is a feature
called code coverage the idea here is
that you just load up you're out you hit
record in this new item in the drawer
and then we tell you what blocks of code
actually got executed and which ones
didn't so here we've got sort of an
indication that maybe you know I'm not
really using 50% of the code in the
bundle that I'm shipping down and as we
click on that and scroll through the
sources panel you can see that we
highlight in green code that got
executed and red code that didn't in
this case because this is a camera app
I've got a lot of code for actually
doing cross browser saving a file to an
export so I can probably be lazily
loading in other things we can do like
most of us here probably using a
transpiler of some sort to use all the
juicy new features javascript has got
but the reality is that you know cross
browser es2015 support is in a
relatively good place right now we don't
always need to be you know sending
people down es5 so if you're shipping an
experience using babel today i strongly
encourage you to try out babel preset
ends this will basically only transpile
code for the browsers that need it and
just keep everything else in es2015
let's check that out if you happen to be
using low - check out babel plugin low -
this is sort of a neat transform that
will rewrite your low - code so it only
uses the modules that you're actually
using in your source rather than the
entire package so check that out - this
week we also announced after a very long
wait
support for es2015 modules in chrome
thank you this is something that will
hopefully encourage again a little bit
less transformation and is something
that will open up a few more
opportunities for interesting loading
experiences across the board the next
thing I like to do
is order loading thoughtfully you know
more than anybody else in the stack you
know what is important to your user
journey and what needs to be sent down
earlier on than anything else something
that we recently also shipped in dev
tools to help with this is a feature
called network request blocking that's
in canary right now the idea here is
that in the network waterfall for any
site you can right-click on a network
request and you can block it or you can
block the domain and take a look at what
impact that has on the overall critical
path of your site I'm particularly
useful if you've got a lot of
third-party code that's slowing you down
and finally cache aggressively and
granularly cache as much as you can
locally that's both with HTTP cache but
also using serviceworker caching at
Google we've been trying to ramp up our
investment in serviceworker for a lot of
our flagship apps inbox has been using
serviceworker quite a lot and recently
saw a 10% improvement in time to
interactive just by making sure that
they're using it for things like static
resource caching now about three years
ago I was speaking at CSS comp and we
spent the whole talk sort of optimizing
jazz comp that you and I thought you
know given that I'm back here it'd be
kind of fun to do that again at a much
shorter rate but also a little bit may
be unorthodox plea so what we're going
to do is we're going to hack chrome to
make j/s confi you load a little bit
faster
this guy's not in fact a hacker he's
just like scrolling through his web pack
on fake or something
so you dive into C++ in chrome and you
find this file called resource fetcher
and resource fetcher is one of these
files I know nobody can see this so
let's just zoom in here this is one of
these files that define how chrome
actually handles the prioritization for
different types of resources so your CSS
your JavaScript your images I don't
expect anybody to read this so here's
the table of how we actually handle this
layout blocking resources like CSS and
fonts get the highest priority load in
layout blocking phase resources like
scripts or images that happens being the
viewport get a medium priority and then
everything from your
basing scripts to images that are
outside of the viewport mismatch CSS
they get a much much lower priority
what's interesting about this table
actually is that images in your viewport
get a medium priority and stuff that's
outside of they get a lower one so we
kind of do automatic lazy loading of
images to some extent by default that's
great but as a developer you probably
care more about where this is exposed
for you so in the network panel there's
a column called priority that will tell
you exactly what we're already was used
for any of the resources that you wanted
to load so we're back here and the part
of chrome that we're going to hack is
we're actually going to change
absolutely every single type of resource
to load with an extremely high priority
it sounds like a great idea right so
let's let's do that and that's going to
fix all of our problems and I can just
end the talk there right we could ship a
new browser we could call it so I
discovered Germany it's got this
wonderful world called vers lemon
discern which that's a terrible
pronunciation but it means when you try
to fix something but you actually made
it a whole lot worse and I did so this
is the original filmstrip for a jazz
talk to you and this is what it looks
like when everything is considered high
priority we've actually completely
shifted first meaningful paint way back
performance is worse lesson there when
everything is high priority
nothing is and I ended up fixing this by
going through the different types of
resources that are used in this
particular page and trying to figure out
okay well are the image of the most
important things the CSS and as it turns
out it was the CSS and fonts so let's do
this right by the browser we talked
already about sort of at the high level
how never for process work but there's a
piece of this puzzle that I didn't quite
dive into and that's the browser preload
scanner now browsers like Chrome have
got a document parser and as we go
through the tokenization phase of
actually reading through all the
different tokens that compose your HTML
we will go and try to fetch those
resources and start processing them if
we run into like a blocking script
that's going to stop the document parser
in its tracks which is why we have the
sort of fallback thing that
load scanner which is able to look ahead
even when the you know dr. MacArthur is
blocked and find other resources that we
can continue to fetch and process when
this change was first introduced in
chrome I believe it introduced like a
20% improvement over all the time so the
preload scanner is pretty cool but we
run into this other interesting
challenge which is discovery no browser
knows exactly what sequence of things to
load to make sure that your page is
going to be fast you more than anybody
else again know what's important in your
page whether it's your web pack bundles
that need to be loaded early on or
something else and so to address
discoverability and the ability for you
as an author to be able to say what you
consider to be high priority you can use
things like link rel preload which works
with scripts and stylesheets and other
types of resources and it's basically a
declarative fetch that tells the browser
that you consider something to be high
priority now this is what the impact of
using it on you know a site that happens
to be using webpack looked like you [ __ ]
you kind of shift all of the yellow
that's on the right right all the way to
the left at parse time I seeing this
pattern being used increasingly in
progressive web apps where it's having a
positive impact on time to interactive
for a lot of folks so I check that out
if you're interested in actually hooking
this up to your build process today I
wrote a web pack plug-in called preload
web pack plug-in they can do this for a
synchronous chunks as well as like
normal chunks so check it out if you
find it interesting over on chrome the
polymer team worked on an app a while
ago called shop and the idea behind shop
was trying to see you know if we if we
use the web platform and the web
platform features that are available to
us today just how fast we make a modern
web experience that was sort of
non-trivial and shop kind of checked
that off it was able to reach sort of
granular loading you're able to tap on
things and everything is just really
nice and buttery smooth on mobile but
how did they accomplish this so they
used a pattern we came up with about
last year called purple and the idea
with purple is that you try to make sure
that you're sending down the most
important things for the user as early
on as possible
you push the minimal code needed for a
route you render that route for next
routes you're able to precache anything
using service workers so that not only
is that stuff already available locally
in the disk cache when they try
navigating to it but it's constantly
available on repeat visits in addition
for JavaScript using serviceworker we'll
actually early on opt you into v8 code
cache which will save you a little bit
of time on things like parsing
compilation and then the pattern
suggests lazy loading code that you need
for other parts of your user experience
so let's take a look at what that
actually looks like so this is um this
is shop before any optimizations were
applied you see sort of this this step
pattern in the timeline this is a CB 2
with 3G and remember that little block
at the very start we're not actually
seeing any any activity we're going to
go back to that limit later with preload
we actually changed the shape of that
completely so we've gone from this to
something looks like this basically
we've shifted our time a little bit
everything is now going to be attempting
to load in parallel to some extent and
that's start that starts shaving off
some time over the overall user
experience but it still comes with the
cost of multiple round trips and this is
where things like hb2 server push can
actually come in useful
now what push allows us to do is as an
author specify using a manifest the
files that we know are going to be
critical to the user journey instead of
just you know pushing down the request
you know sending the browser some HTML
with spending to be parsed when we send
back that an is real HTML we can also
start sending down a list of files that
are super important to start fetching
for the experience effectively we're
filling up server think time we're today
in a lot of cases we're not actually
doing that so hey speed to server push
is great for that and the impact that it
had on this particular app was quite
stark again we've shaved thousands of
milliseconds off of the overall time for
this app to get interactive and to load
in general using this technique
unfortunately hb2 server pushes not a
silver bullet by any means
it's not particularly Kasia we're in a
perfect world we have the ability to
have a cache digest or something that
lets you know what exactly is in your
user cache and so it's very easy to run
into cases where you know every single
time someone comes to your site you're
just force pushing them you know the
same set of files even if it's inside
their cache which is not exactly ideal
so push versus preload you know push can
cut out a whole RCT it's not cache weird
there's no real prioritization in place
preload is particularly useful because
in addition to what push can do it also
you know sports cross-origin requests
got load narrower events got content
negotiation but how do we address this
issue of h2 push not particularly
knowing what's in the cache what we can
use serviceworker if we have a
serviceworker registered in such a way
that instead of going to the network
every single time that we need you know
more resources to be fetched we're just
trying to get them locally based on what
is already cached we avoid this issue of
needing cache digests and it makes this
entire setup relatively sane for shop in
particular this meant that on repeat
visits once you tie absolutely
everything in purple together you're
actually able to boot up and get
interactive in just a few hundred
milliseconds it's quite a powerful
pattern so preload is good for moving
the start download time of an asset
closer to the initial request and push
is good for cutting out a full RTT if
you have a serviceworker
thanks to Sam Saucony for a bunch of the
research that he did in this area the
next thing I want to talk about is how a
lot of this stuff can apply to the apps
that you're probably building today out
of interest how many people here are
using react as a part of their default
stack almost everybody or good good size
the audience so I had the privilege of
being able to work with Twitter on their
new progressive web app Twitter light I
wanted to talk a little bit about the
learnings that we had there so Twitter
started off with this which was their
old mobile web experience and sort of
the server-side render thing it was
really really slow and it wasn't
particularly happy didn't particularly
encourage users to get engaging with the
app this is the new progressive web app
the Twitter shipped very very recently
Twitter light and one of the
accomplishments that they had by taking
advantage of some of the primitives that
we just talked about is that they're
able to get interactive in under five
seconds on 3G which is quite a nice feet
now this didn't come without an amount
of pain you know so you can use you know
modern frameworks like react to shift
aggressive web apps but you're going to
have to put the work in to cut down on
how much you know application code
you've got going on there you're going
to have to take advantage of code
splitting you're going to have to make
sure that you're just granularly loading
and serving things in as well as you can
so when Twitter first started working on
this app early on they they had a
relatively poor time to interactive
score so they were looking at about 15
16 milliseconds before anyone could
actually start tapping around the
interface so not too far away from where
a lot of us probably are today most of
their critical path was dominated by
time spent in script just booting up and
so they started taking a look at
patterns like purple and and how they
could take advantage of them the first
thing they introduced was support for
DNS prefetch so the ability to you know
just specify declaratively what servers
you want to start warming your DNS
connections up to that led to an 18%
perform performance improvement on what
they initially had just for at least
hitting things like FMP next they
investigated using preload for their
critical scripts I can't tell you how
easy this stuff is to set up like this
will take you you know if you're using a
static site it's probably less than ten
minutes if you're using something full
stack it will probably take you an hour
but it's we're trying out just to see if
it actually has a perceivable
improvement on your site so they ended
up reloading their critical script so
this is like their vendor bundle their
synchronous chip scripts as well as
their their main scripts that lets with
36% improvement on their overall time to
interactive next they put work into
actually putting pixels on the screen
much faster now Twitter is one of those
experiences that are very you know
meteor rich there's a lot of images in
there and so it's unsurprising the media
and images one of the things that were
slowing them down render wise now one of
the things they did was they used
request I'll call back
we defer loading of some of the images
in their timeline and that led to a four
times improvement on the render
performance ric is kind of awesome
definitely worth exploring another thing
that they noticed was and this was kind
of it's it's so silly but images are
still such a big part of what slows us
down these days they noticed that they
were still sending down relatively large
images that were not the right height or
width that were still encoded you know
sub-optimally and we're taking a long
time to decode as soon as they hit
chrome they went through the process of
actually optimizing that and that shaved
off a whole lot of time on their image
decodes helped them to make sure that as
you scroll through the timeline images
are at least not one of those things
that are causing you a bottleneck
another thing that they introduced was
data saver mode this is this idea that
you as a user can say well I've got a
limited data plan I just want you to not
show any images or videos unless I
actually tap on them and this led to a
70 percent improvement in many cases on
the amount of data consumed by the
application if you're looking at a web
platform level at what we're doing to
try these types of experiences we've got
the save data client int that you can
use and Twitter going to investigate
using that next then you've got free
cash
so initially Twitter Lite didn't have
support for anything offline or
serviceworker caching and what they did
was they incremental II took an approach
to adopting serviceworker they started
off by first of all statically sort of
caching their scripts the emoji they're
used whenever you try DMing someone or
applying to tweets as well as CSS and
then they ramp that up over time to
include things like application shell
caching so UI caching now what that did
on repeat visits was it took load time
down from six point ten seconds down to
one point four nine seconds so when you
after the first time that you visit
Twitter light it feels instant coming
back and trying to navigate across
different views it's pretty powerful now
I was cheeky and asked twitter to like
host 20 different versions
their site so I could go and profile
them and they were kind enough to do
that now on second load without a
serviceworker after some of these
changes they saw that they were 47%
faster on second load so repeat visits
with a surface worker they're 65 percent
faster and you've got lazy load so
remember when we were looking so this is
a lighthouse report if I didn't mention
it before
remember when we were saying earlier
that their time to interactive scores
kind of sucked and needed a little bit
of work well breaking that work up was
one of the first things they needed to
do so they have to do these large blocks
of like monolithic JavaScript bundles
that I know people are like you know
some people just don't look at me I'm
not doing that but a lot of people
actually still do this and that's
relatively slow to load on mobile if you
have a relatively large bundle even if
you think that like you know a few
hundred kilobytes isn't a lot that's
still extra work the browser has to do
to parse and compile that code before it
can even you know start to boot it up so
initially their bundles were taking five
and a half seconds five and a half
second dish to get ready before code
splitting and then they had this great
moment where they're trying to figure
out how you're supposed to configure web
pack and are still having the best of
times with it
I hear it's gone better with web pack -
we'll see and one of the things that
they ended up doing was this is this is
a lot of what their code splitting
looks like beyond just just using
require done ensure they're just making
sure that they're correctly using sort
of vendor splitting for all of their
bundles across different views Twitter
ended up creating something like 40
different a synchronous chunks that are
granularly loaded as you navigate from
one view to the other and the impact
that that had on their experience was
that that actual bundle ended up only
taking about three seconds to fully
process and it improved their overall
times interactive by the end of it
they're actually doing much better than
this now but by the end of it they were
getting interactive in about 5.7 seconds
which is still impressive as an
investment in just code splitting and
some relatively low friction ideas
around efficient loading so
one other thing that they ended up
finding was incredibly invaluable and
have been coming back to it pretty
regularly is just making sure that
they're using bundle analyzers like
webpack bundle analyzer to find out what
low-hanging fruit they have in their
bundles I keep running into people they
don't realize that moment J s or other
libraries are actually a big part of
their bundles and can probably be
trimmed down so if you're not using
things like web pack bundle analyzer or
source map Explorer do check them out
they do generally lead to at least
understanding a little bit more about
what it is you're sending down the wire
and in Twitter's case they were making
sure that they were using the bundle
analyzer plugin so that every single
time someone was actually working
directly on the application they could
see what impact that ended up having on
their bundle site on their actual bundle
shape so performance is sort of this
continuous game of measuring for areas
to improve there isn't a single thing
that you can do and then just leave it
where your site is going to you know
always be fast regardless of the devices
that your users end up trying it out on
for anyone that is interested in sort of
getting involved with more continuous
performance profiling you know where
your team are staying on top of it and
you're building up a performance culture
I'm happy to encourage you trying out
lighthouse it's one of the projects that
we work on lighthouse sort of is a is an
auditing tool for both performance
metrics but also progressive web app
features and general web performance of
web platform best practices and I'm also
happy to suggest trying out calibre by
Ben Schwartz calibre is sort of great in
that it allows you over time to track
everything from your bundle size through
to different performance metrics and see
you know what impact your different
employees had over time so check that
out and I'd also encourage people to
check out web page test integration with
your git hooks housing comm is a
progressive web app that did this and
basically they have this really awesome
setup where any time someone tries to
submit a new PR for a feature it runs it
through web page test and will include a
filmstrip
at the very bottom of your Pia
are to show exactly what impact that had
on user experience so with that I hope
you found this little journey into
loading useful I hope you found the
story about some of the experiences we
had with Twitter useful I know that you
know Twitter of Twitter is great it also
sometimes feels like group therapy where
no one ever it gets any better that it's
it's great so yeah if if you're
interested in learning a little bit more
about loading we started a new blog over
on a crime scene called reloading on
medium so medium.com slash reloading and
we intend on publishing more material
there over the next coming months about
everything from h to server push through
to broadly Gretz lee and a lot of the
other work that we're doing in the
loading space and that's it for me thank
you
[Applause]
you